I vividly remember the civil war in
Somalia of course there was fear there
it was not a safe place for us and
that's the reason why we left our own
country when Hooda landed in the US she
had no idea that her neighbors would be
afraid of her I've been told that there
are certain customs in the Somali
culture that I'm not supposed to
transgress and I don't know what they
are I think we need to know more about
their religion where they're coming from
because I was understood you never ever
shake hands people are genuinely
interested in getting to know us that's
why we're coming today in dialog in
large numbers we want to help them
overcome the fear of a nonsense my name
is Sarah Ibrahim and I started dying on
dialog and I'm refugee from Somalia my
name is Minnie Driver I am an actress a
singer and I am an immigrant I believe
nothing is more American than its
immigrants so I'm teaming up with great
big story to celebrate those that have
come here and left their mark
[Music]
I was 19 years old when I came to
Minnesota it was a long journey during
the Somali Civil War
large numbers of Somalis relocated to
Minnesota today the state has the
largest population of Somalis in North
America but the influx of Somali
refugees has created tension in the
community moving into this central
Minnesota community people are curious
about our culture and who we are and
where we came from of course we do have
challenges I am Muslim I am black I am a
refugee but I'm also Somali American so
instead of being angry and complaining
my husband and I turned it to the other
side and said we should do something
about this so Hooda and her husband
started dine and dialogue a bimonthly
dinner gathering where the central
community can meet their Somali
neighbors people were afraid to ask
questions that they thought were
inappropriate or offensive and when
individuals usually come to those
dinners we say ask us any burning
questions that you might have questions
like what is the significance of the
hijab why do Muslims pray five times a
day so instead of assuming I want people
to be open-minded the first time and
dialogue we didn't know who was coming
we just sent an open invitation to all
my husband and I couldn't believe when
we saw 50 registration and we were like
we need to make sure that we have enough
food for these people coming
who'da helps cook a massive Somali meal
for all who attend and she attributes
some of her program's success to the
meals themselves the food is one of the
main contributors really bringing people
together there were a lot of people who
told me that they never had any Somali
food before and that they love the
sambusa we make sure that the samosas
are ready to fry it when we make rice we
make sure that we have the right meat we
have got me we make sure that we have
chicken and beef
and Somali tea so do not leave this room
today without knowing someone so get to
know your neighbors
ask questions thank you very much I feel
that I want to be compassionate feel
that I want to care I'm just afraid that
I'm gonna do something that's gonna
offend somebody once you're open to the
idea of somebody being different then
there's more common than there is
actually differences but if you are
afraid to make a mistake and today she
continues to host this open forum every
other month and hopes to expand into
other communities I'm hoping to spread a
no dialogue throughout Minnesota I
devoted my life to build a better
community for all of us and I want
people to know that we're proud
Americans
we're taxpayers will contribute into the
economy and that we're here to stay
you
[Music]